I'm gonna walk you through my thought
process on how I built this responsive
weather forecast page typically when I'm
trying to pick my breakpoints I'll start
in my desktop browser with my viewport
set as small as I can get it I also like
to have the chrome dev tools open
because it shows me the screen width in
the upper right hand corner as I resize
the window next I'll slowly start
resizing the window looking to see when
the content tells me that it wants a
breakpoint and probably somewhere here
at about the 550 pixel mark looks like a
good place anything wider and the spaces
between these columns are going to
become too big in my code
I've already got my viewport set and a
default set of styles that are applied
for any viewport width I'll add whether
medium dot CSS to the head with a media
query that checks for a screen and if
the viewport width is greater than 550
pixels great I'll switch back to the
browser hit refresh and start to resize
perfect at 550 pixels things look
exactly like I expect because that
breakpoint was only at 550 pixels I
think I probably want to add another one
otherwise we'll run into the same
problem with too much space between
columns I easily have a room for another
one
since most desktops and laptops are
significantly wider than 550 pixels I'll
go through the same process and I'll
continue to expand the viewport until it
looks like I need another breakpoint
again I'm looking for a place where the
content tells me that it wants a
breakpoint 700 pixels looks to be right
about the right place so I'm gonna go
ahead and add one here again I'll add a
new style sheet but this time pointed at
whether large dot CSS it'll check for
screen and check to see if the viewport
width is at least 700 pixels quick
refresh in the browser and resize and
we've got it things are looking good
I could keep adding breakpoints but in
this case I think having two breakpoints
is enough essentially one at a small
viewport one at a medium viewport and
one at a large viewport okay that's
enough of me talking now it's your turn
to give it a try